I think it's quite significant reaction
actually it suggests to me that the
police are taking seriously the rest
allegations rumors and all sorts of
things have been going around and that
they are now going to look into them
properly and it may lead and our hope it
does too then criminal investigations so
that the police and the judicial
authorities will be looking to actual
investigations of real people dead or
alive and whatever is learnt from this
as well must feed into the overarching
inquiry which is now underway under the
new judge justice lil Goddard too so I
think this is a significant and a good
development the whole idea of the police
investigator the police in this case is
to make them more efficient process so
it can feed into that inquiry but at the
end of the day this is the police
investigating the police and the IPCC
overseeing this they don't have the
power to compel for example retired
officers even to speaking to them so can
its way to be effective oh sure and
that's part of the problem i pc see that
it's fairly toothless and it's certainly
toothless when it comes two officers who
are no longer serving officers as well
but this is about investigating whether
criminal activity has taken place and
whether there has been a cover-up and
lots of people have been suspicious with
good reason that a cover-up over many
years has been preventing these things
being propped investigated and brought
to light many years ago when they
happened we're talking about things
going back into 70s and 80s only forward
results in come of this and either
there's no truth to any of these
allegations and I think given the amount
of evidence we've seen or alleged
allegations coming forth that's very
unlikely secondly those policing
competence at the time and I think I
can't believe that thirdly were pleased
covering up for other police who were
themselves involved in some sort of
sexual abuse or were they being
suppressed their activities of
investigations by orders on high from
politicians not say a lot of people
think it leads right to the top now I
said all along the home sector said all
along that VIPs be they MPs with a
celebrities with a top judges policemen
or whatever should absolutely be
investigated along with anybody else
they are not immune and if they've
committed sexual abuse against children
they are no less repugnant to
individuals and criminals than taxi
drivers Asian gangs teachers doctors or
whatever so
we need this investigation to be
absolutely transparent and to give some
some relief to the victims and the
survivors that this is being taken
seriously and all the stones are being
unturned and I fear they are going to
unravel and the reveals and pretty murky
things lurking beneath those stones but
if we talk about full transparency why
not as the shadow home secretary
suggested have an independent inquiry in
this case but we've got so many
independent gaara's going on within the
National Health Service within the BBC
within education within children's homes
we've got them coming out of our ears
which is why there's overarching inquiry
to try bring all these different strands
together to really get to the heart of
how did society how did the
establishment how did institutions allow
this form of abuse of children to go on
undetected or unprosecuted for all those
years and investigating the police
themselves and their role in to these
verse allegations involving child abuse
in South London and potentially in
Westminster as well are an important
part of that so let the IPCC do their
job they're now going to have the
spotlight on them they're not going to
have to cover anything up and the police
actually have referred this to the IPCC
at themselves so they've shown willing
and I think that's a very important sign
as well we all want to get to the bottom
of this this does no one any good be
their politicians be they senior police
officials be they judges or anybody else
involved with this we need to get to the
truth and if there are perpetrators
culprits criminals still at large they
need to be brought to book these are
historic cases we're talking about here
potentially but when you talk about
what's going on at the moment I mean
there's been talk all you know is it's a
lot postcode lottery really when it
comes to how victims today dealt with
police forces is there a crisis of
confidence still in our police forces in
the way that they actually handled it
well we're looking here at historic
cases going back to the to the 70s but
what I'm most concerned about is have we
got a child protection system in 2015
that is fit for purpose and are well
that is the big question and I think we
are better than we were some years ago
and if you are
me our children in this country safer
than they were 10 years ago 20 years ago
when Jimmy Savile was up to all his vile
abuse and I think the answer is
absolutely yes but it is a postcode lost
in certain parts of the country in as
we've seen from Rochester from rod room
from the Oxfordshire cases at recently
in too many of those cases people in
positions of authority and trust you are
there to look after children be the
police officers social workers teachers
and others did not take those
allegations seriously for all sorts of
politically correct reasons in some
cases they were told to go away and they
were swept under the carpet there is no
excuse for that now and I don't think
anybody can really say now that this is
not being taken seriously and if there's
one upside one compensation for this
whole vial story is that people are far
more aware of child sexual exploitation
than ever before that it can happen to
anybody and we all have a duty to be
vigilant and those people responsible
for it are increasingly being thrown in
jail for a very long time absolute thank
you so much joining us tonight thank you